من جانب قال رئيس اركان الجيش الاسرائيلي
هرتس هاليفي ان الضغط العسكري هو الكثير
باستعاده المحتجزين الاسرائيليين في قطاع
غزه وجاء حديث هاليفي خلال تقييم امني
عقده في شمال قطاع غزه بحضور عدد من كبار
الضباط بالجيش
الاسرائيلي ان الدهم وتركيز الجهود
والاداره الصحيحه للمعركه الى جانب عنصر
المفاجاه والخداع كل هذا سيؤدي الى تعميق
الانجاز المزيد من الارهابيين القتلى
والمزيد من القاده القتلى والمزيد من
البنيه التحتيه المدمره امل ان يقودنا هذا
الضغط ايضا الى تحقيق هدف اكثر اهميه وهو
اعاده المختطفين جميعهم اننا نحاول جاهدين
من اجل ذلك لن يحدث هذا بدون ضغط عسكري
يجب ان نوهم انفسنا ولهذا السبب نضغط على
القطع باكمله بالنار في مناوره منظمه
بغارات مفاجئه وسنواصل القيام بذلك بطريقه
نوعيه